wir reden gleich weiter denn jetzt
spricht hier markus söder sein grußwort
auf dem cdu parteitag der kleinen
schwester csu überbringen und
[Applaus]
darf ich eine gratulation aussprechen
und respekt ich habe das gestern
teilweise mitverfolgen können in den
live übertragungen
mal abgesehen davon dass es einfach
wieder freude macht zusammen zu kommen
zusammen parteitage zu feiern nach
dieser schweren corona zeit es passt
halt einfach zu uns wenn wir uns
unterhaken wenn wir zusammenstehen denn
wir sind keine solchen mist cremigen wie
die linken wir sind eine union die auch
sich unterhaken deswegen toller
parteitag gut dass wir zusammenstehen
und gratulation zu diesen zwei tagen
[Applaus]
es ist ein tolles signal gewesen von
entschlossenheit und geschlossenheit was
in den letzten 2 tage gezeigt hat ich
weiss 20 21 war nicht unser bestes jahr
sind viele fehler gemacht worden von
allen natürlich auch von mir aber wir
haben daraus gelernt
ich sage es ganz offen
[Applaus]
wir haben daraus gelernt und ich möchte
sagen der neustadt
ist nicht nur besser gelaufen als es die
linken erhofft haben sondern ich darf
das ganz persönlich sagen die
zusammenarbeit in fraktion und partei
ganz besonders mit eurem vorsitzenden
lieber friedrich läuft exzellent
besser als wir beides wahrscheinlich
erwartet hätten wenn ich das so sagen
darf ja und diese zusammenarbeit und ist
bewusst sein dass eine union nur erfolg
haben kann ist auch die grundlage
gewesen für die erfolgreichen wahlen
durch starke ministerpräsidenten in
schleswig holstein in
nordrhein-westfalen und ich bin total
optimistisch meine damen und herren das
auch in niedersachsen genau das gleiche
möglich ist denn eines ist doch klar
herr weil ist ein urgestein der spd und
der ampel und wer die ampel nicht mehr
will der muss union wählen in
niedersachsen etwas anderes macht
überhaupt keinen sinn
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir zwei jahre schwerste
krise überstanden mit corona etwas das
über nacht kam und das ist zu bewältigen
galt und im frühjahr hatten die alle die
hoffnung des jahr wird anders wir hatten
alle den wunsch den aufbruch zu erleben
das miteinander zu fühlen und
schon ging es erneut los horst seehofer
zu mir gesagt immer wenn du denkst es
geht bergauf kommt einer mit dem hammer
drauf und er meinte nicht unser
persönliches verhältnis liebe freundin
freunde ja
und genau so war es in diesem jahr die
eine katastrophe wird von einer anderen
abgelöst
es ist eine schwere zeit und wir stehen
ihr habt es gestern deutlich gemacht
auch an der seite und ganz besonders an
der seite der ukraine aber liebe
freundin freunde kein vorwurf an die
neue regierung das ist schwere
entscheidungen zu treffen sind aber mein
eindruck ist und der eindruck ein großen
teil ist unseres volkes ist dass diese
neue regierung
zunehmend überfordert ist und nicht in
der lage ist die schwere dieser
entscheidungen auch zu treffen und dort
erfolgreich zu sein
[Applaus]
noch vor wochen ein lässiges ein cooles
ein sehr selbstbewusstes auftreten und
man spürt geradezu die angst und
nervosität bei der ampel dass sie den
erwartungen nicht gerecht werden kann
diese woche im bundestag
eine klare präzise rede unseres
parteivorsitz und friedrich merz und was
war die antwort ein schreiender
bundeskanzler
mein name ist allemal eine sache muss er
selber entscheiden aber ich finde
während in den letzten monaten eher wie
ein schlumpf wirkte wird der langsam wie
karamell ich will keinen streit einen
bundeskanzler in deutschland erleben
meine damen und herren
und ein tag drauf
der wirtschaftsminister
nicht wie sonst erklären philosophisch
weit schweifen und selbstbewusst sondern
meine damen und herren im sound
des eigenen selbstmitleid frieden und
angreifen und versuchen zu verteidigen
im endeffekt nichts anders als ein
jammern der posterboy der einst zu
überdecken sucht liebe freunde und
freunde das in den letzten wochen noch
einmal schwer entscheidungen
handwerkliche fehler ein fehlendes
gesamtkonzept und letztlich ein täglich
heftiger ampel streit stattfindet ich
kann nur eines sagen in den schlimmsten
zeiten der groko war es eher eine
romantische beziehung als das was fdp
spd und grüne derzeit in berlin abgeben
so kann es kein vertrauen für die
mehrzahl der bevölkerung geben
[Applaus]
lieber friedrich was ist denn im moment
noch ihr einziges argument
wenn du die punkte ansprichst das
argument ist jetzt immer die letzten 16
jahre waren so schlimm jetzt will ich
auch mal nicht deutlich sagen dieses
narrativ wird ja auch gern von den
medien übernommen was ist denn in diesem
16 jahren wirklich passiert warum musste
denn die union überhaupt einspringen
damals es gab vorgezogene neuwahlen das
war der start der unions zeit und warum
weil es fünf millionen arbeitslose gab
und rot-grün damals nicht mehr in der
lage waren weiter wusste und was ist
seitdem passiert von fünf millionen
arbeitslosen zur niedrigsten
arbeitslosigkeit
schlimmste krisen wie die finanzkrise
die euro-krise migration krone alles
überwunden und für unser land gut durch
gesteuert eines will ich mal sagen wenn
diejenigen immer auf die letzten 16
jahre verweisen ich würde mir gerne
wünschen dass sie ein bisschen von dem
was wir in diesen krisenzeiten erbracht
haben nur annähernd umsetzen können
lasst uns stolz darauf sagen wir haben
deutschland regiert wir haben es gut
durch die krise geführt besser als
einzige regierung
also klar schwere entscheidungen
die frage ist tut man wirklich alles um
dem anspruch gerecht zu werden die
ukraine zu unterstützen ich weiß nicht
was ihr eindruck ist meiner ist das
wichtigste wo man es jetzt geht wer die
unterstützung mit material an waffen
oder
werde jetzt das wichtigste
[Applaus]
die bundeswehr nur seltsam zögerlich die
motive sind mir nicht erklärbar
wo sind die protagonisten der
verteidigungsministerien liebe freundin
freunde nennt größte tat ist bislang war
5000 helme als entscheidenden beitrag
für diesen konflikt zu liefern seitdem
lebt sie wahrscheinlich auf sylt ich
weiß es nicht ich
weiß nicht wo diejenigen sind jetzt da
wird zuständig wir lieben grüne die
ständig davon reden wir bräuchten mehr
waffen aber im ergebnis nichts zustande
bringen die uns übrigens vorwerfen wir
seien nicht bundeswehr freundlich genug
mal bietet zu der wahrheit wir stehen
und standen immer zur bundeswehr aber
wer hat denn die letzten jahrzehnte bei
jedem ostermarsch gegen die bundeswehr
demonstriert wer hat denn bei jedem
gelöbnis gepfiffen wer hat in jedem
bundeswehr jugendoffizier angegriffen
der in den schulen informieren wollte
über die bereitschaft der streitkräfte
für unser land wir haben keinen
nachholbedarf was bundeswehr betrifft
und ich glaube anton hofreiter erst dann
dass er für die bundeswehr ist wenn er
sich endlich an ordentlichen
militärischen haarschnitt zu liebe
freunde freunde vorher nicht keinen fall
der eine teil klappt nichts funktioniert
der andere teil nicht falsch so schönig
steht so jeder sanktions entscheidung
ich habe aber in den frühen mp cars und
die kolleginnen kollegen die da sind
folge da warst du dabei immer fragt eure
strategie dass wir aussteigen
entscheiden wir eigentlich selbst
bestimmt ob wir uns unabhängig machen
von russland oder wer es am ende
derjenige der die hand am gas schalten
ein nein hier wir sind die einzigen wir
zeigen wo es langgeht
es bringt sich zumindest gefühl auf
meine damen und herren das gegenteil der
fall ist putin treibt mit uns ein übles
spiel an einem tagen ist die turbine
kaputt andermatter hausmeister urlaub
was weiß ich
und während wir jeden tag mehr geld
überweisen wegen der explodierenden
preise
war fackelt er das gas eigentlich für
anderes bestimmt wer in die atmosphäre
schwieriger geht es nicht jetzt will ich
eine sagen
es kommt mittlerweile ein punkt wo wir
zwei mal und sorgen müssen
natürlich müssen wir uns sorgen und
helfen der ukraine
aber wenn die bundesaußenminister nicht
kann nicht genau sagen was sie gesagt
hat ich habe es nur gelesen aber den
eindruck erweckt dass ihre sorge für das
eigene land für die eigene bevölkerung
für die menschen in unserem land ihn
nicht so wichtig wer kann ich nur eines
sagen wir müssen uns auch um die eigene
bevölkerung kümmern und deswegen ist das
zentrale ziel warme wohnungen
bezahlbares essen liebe freundin freunde
bezahlbare energie und sichere
arbeitsplätze das ist das was eine
regierung als grund aufgabe als pflicht
zu
[Applaus]
was ist denn jetzt eigentlich passiert
in den letzten monaten ist er seit
gestern
wo ist das gas
italienern andere vermelden wir sind
sicher beim gas haben verträge mit katar
abgeschlossen was ist denn eigentlich in
deutschland passiert es gab manche von
uns und auch journalisten jemand etwas
hämisch als habe ich zum emir von katar
gefahren ist und dort ein hof nix
gemacht hat jetzt das ist nicht schlimm
da kann auf einem bein hüpfen
hauptsache es kommt was raus das
ergebnis bis heute ist 0 von jeder reise
kehrt die bundesregierung zurück
bestenfalls mit dem versprechen und mit
der botschaft in einigen jahren gebe es
was
warum hat man nicht mit pipelines
schneller begonnen warum nicht überall
warum müssen private konzeption zb jetzt
in lubmin an der ostsee entstehen um den
östlichen und die südlichen bundesländer
zu versorgen warum wurde das nicht getan
täuscht euch bitte nicht
80% speicher voll heißt noch gar nichts
erstens ist nicht überall gleich im
süden deutlich schlechter zweites mal
müssen nach dem chef der
bundesnetzagentur ein grüner
bis zum ersten april wieder 40 prozent
der speicher noch voll sein es ist nur
das prinzip hoffnung auf die wetterkarte
liebe freundin freunde und anstatt
ersatz zu besorgen
erleben der typische vorschläge wie wir
sie von den grünen kennen kalt duschen
wer von euch weil wir zwar keiner gerne
warmduscher sein aber wer wer wer duscht
denn eigentlich zum beispiel gestern
andere heute früh kalt
ganz wenige mehr versucht seinen kindern
in der winterzeit wirklichen mensch kalt
duschen ist das super start in den tag
der nächste vorschlag ist nur noch den
waschlappen überall zu benutzen
verbietet sich das kopfkino liebe
freunde
und die und die berliner senatorin der
grünen sagt ja ich selber reduziert
jeden tag meine wäsche am liebsten auf
null muss ich eine sagen
ich will mich nicht mit den persönlichen
hygieneverhältnissen der grünen
beschäftigen aber die sollen lieber für
ersatz energie besorgen als den menschen
schlauer ratschläge geben liebe freunde
das ist doch kein konzept für
deutschland
[Applaus]
und wenn sie dann was machen groß
angekündigt
ministerkonferenz per telefon einberufen
der durchbruch ist die gasanlage ist wie
sie der durchbruch um die rettung des
winter sei die gasanlage nicht
einmal in den spinnstuben der ampel
parteien glaubt man diese these noch die
gasanlage ist murks
übrigens wurde vor einigen wochen
angekündigt sie wird verbessert bis
heute ist nichts passiert
der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat das
übrigens mit folgenden worten begründet
naja dieser gasmarkt ist so kompliziert
da kann man nicht so richtig
durchblicken und es kann nicht richtig
verstehen wenn das die
bundesentwicklungsministerin sagen würde
dann würde ich sagen was soll's wenn der
zuständige minister in deutschland in
der grössten gaskrise unseres landes
sagt ich habe den überblick verloren und
ich habe da eigentlich keine ahnung
meine damen und herren dann ist das ein
echter blankoscheck ein armutszeugnis
für unser land und ich kann nur eines
sagen diese gas umlage muss weg liebe
freundin freunde wie musste
der minister
hat dann parallel ja monatelang gesagt
na ja wir haben nur ein problem aber
keinen strom problem erinnern sie sich
jetzt haben wir plötzlich doch ein
stromproblem
kamen dass über nacht und
energieexperten union haben monatelang
darauf hingewiesen übrigens auch die
wirtschaft wir vergrößern die
energiekrise deutschlands seit dieser
woche fundamental wir haben nicht nur
jetzt ein riesiges gas sondern auch ein
stromproblem
kann mir jemand wirklich irgend einen
vernünftigen grund erklären warum man in
zeiten wo es auf jede kilowattstunde
strom ankommt um gas zu ersetzen um die
übrigens gefordert not stromheizungen zu
machen weil die forderung der
bundesregierung wie kann man in zeiten
wo alles fehlt selbst entscheiden noch
einmal für zehn millionen haushalte den
strom abzuschalten die entscheidung von
habe klebe freundin freunde die
kernkraft nicht mehr weiterlaufen zu
lassen ist schlicht und einfach falsch
ist zum schaden unseres landes und wir
fordern die anderen ampel partner auf
dies nicht nur zu beklagen sondern zu
ändern im grunde genommen muss die
kompetenz zur energie entzogen und im
bundeskanzleramt gebündelt und dann
anders entschieden werden liebe freundin
freunde sonst drohte im land riesiger
schaden
[Applaus]
wir sind keine kernkraft fans würde ich
mal nicht danke dir auch noch mal für
eine unterstützung waren bei uns im
modernsten kernkraftwerke deutschland
isar 2 und wir haben erlebt und es auch
gehört wie seit monaten bei dem thema
die unwahrheit gesagt wird erst hieß es
die kernenergie sei nicht mehr sicher
durch alle gutachten widerlegt dann ist
es gebe kein personal dabei durch alle
gutachten widerlegt dann hieß es das
weiß es zieht immer ganz gut die bayern
seien sowieso an allem schuld ich will
nur darauf hinweisen an die freunde aus
baden württemberg die lage in bayern und
baden württemberg ist genauso
lieber künftiger ministerpräsident wenn
ich das sagen darf
niedersachsen liegt bei erneuerbaren
energien insgesamt in der gesamtmenge
auf platz eins und bei dir
wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr werden ja
bayern aber auf platz zwei
kleiner werbeblock ja
wir liegen bis aufwind überall vorne und
deswegen ehrlich gesagt ist es auch
unverständig zu versuchen so was zu
machen und am ende doch zwei
kernkraftwerken alle reserve zu geben
die gar nicht funktioniert technisch
umsetzbar ist ich will nur sagen wir
bayern sind wirklich freundlich wir
helfen deutschland gern wir haben zb dem
noch nicht im amt befindlichen
bundeskanzler liebe freundin freunde hat
uns angerufen und sagte liebe bayern
könnt ihr den g 7 gipfel machen ich
dachte eigentlich
ein bundeskanzlers hamburg
wird nach den guten erfahrungen die er
selbst beim g-20-gipfel gemacht hat ja
aber wahrscheinlich hat er gewiss
erinnerungslücken was hamburg betrifft
es kommt ja häufiger vor der zeit liebe
freundin freunde über nur eines sagen
und es geht hier auch wir haben den g 7
gipfel gut organisiert warum weil dort
wo die union regiert es sicheres und
dort wurde union regiert man nicht gegen
sondern für die polizei eintrifft die
unser land sicher markt danke an die
polizistinnen und polizisten
[Applaus]
also woche für woche ausreden beim thema
kernenergie und wenn die pressekonferenz
am montag verfolgt da
pressekonferenz sui generis würde
besonders klugen und dann sagen ja das
sagt jeder betreiber ungefähr das macht
keinen sinn da kommt der minister und
sagt ich ordne das jetzt mal komplett
anders ein
meine damen und herren das konzept von
robert habeck wird in dieser frage
scheitern er riskiert jens spahn hatte
es mehrfach gesagt er riskiert einen
schweren blackout und schaden für unser
land
er trägt dafür die persönliche
verantwortung und der grund ist doch
eindeutig erkennbar es ist pure grüne
ideologie da meldet sich jürgen trittin
aus der gruft
ja
[Applaus]
claudia roth warnt gegen die kernkraft
wie immer und am ende erklärt die
aktuelle
außenministerin berbalk es sei irrsinn
die kernenergie jetzt zu verlängern der
einzige irrsinn ist jetzt abzuschalten
und wisst ihr was daraus deutlich wird
für jeden bürger und bürger die grünen
sind eben nicht liebe freundin freunde
die moderne neue objektive staatspartei
sondern es sind die uralten gleichen
ideologischen linken grünen es bleibt
einfach dabei die ändern sich nicht
die kosten
es fehlt energie an allen ecken und
enden und deutschland in schalding
schlechter zu machen david die
europäische union fordert uns hier auf
allein schon aus gründen der
europäischen netzstabilität ist nichts
zu tun mal vorstellen und gleichzeitig
explodieren die preise das wird liebe
freundin freunde schlimm werden und zwar
jetzt schon sicher viele bürger werden
es mit der zeit erst spüren weil die
abrechnungen erst monat für monat kommen
unser mittelstand hingegen spürte sehr
deutlich dort haben wir preissteigerung
von mehreren hundert prozent
überall wachsen diese enormen
explosionen von preisen und ich sage
euch eines
wir reden im moment davon
geringverdiener zu schützen die wahrheit
ist die breite mitte unseres volkes ist
vom abstieg bedroht es kann sein dass
leute die heute normalverdiener sind am
ende des prozesses geringverdiener sind
und darum noch einmal die aufforderung
an die bundesregierung nicht im
klein-klein zu verheddern sondern wenn
ein entlastungskonzept dann richtig dann
vernünftig dann breit und vor allen
dingen liebe freundin freunde wenn eine
regierung ein entlastungspaket macht von
65 milliarden
und damit alte fehler beseitigt indem
man die renten an renten ausschließt hat
er nicht gewundert dieses nämlich
energie zuschuss gibt es für die die
essen und heizen müssen
essen rennt man rentner nichts heizen
sie nichts eine grobe ungerechtigkeit
von einer partei gemacht die immer noch
glaubt sie sei die bessere
sozialpolitische graf wir sind nämlich
wieder liebe freundin freunde nicht die
spd
aber
fehler die korrigiert werden verdienen
respekt und dank
aber es klaffen beim zweiten blick beim
blick ins kleingedruckte dieses
beschlusses jeden tag neue fragen auf
strompreis bremse europäisch wie geht es
jetzt soll es brüssel machen oder wir
ein basistarif der gemacht für den strom
haben sie mal verstanden was das heißt
es soll jetzt durch den bund entschieden
werden wie viel strom jeder haushalt zur
verfügung haben darf
es entscheiden es künftig jemand nach
dem motto wie früher
lebensmittelmarken rabatt rationierung
und dass der komplette im mittelstand
vergessen wurde und dass selbst
zuständige minister in einer talkshow in
talkshows sind immer nicht einfach da
müssen wir alle ja sondern dass wenn die
unionsleute da sind dann sprüht geradezu
die interviewer in der regel vor
freundlichkeit aber
dass der minister in einer talkshow sagt
mir dann produzieren wir halt nicht und
dann ich produziert mal nicht und hat
halt keine insolvenz zu befürchten
nochmal wer nicht produziert verdient
nichts muss aber mitarbeiter bezahlen
muss sozialversicherungsbeiträge bezahlt
muss steuer bezahlen wenn ein
wirtschaftsminister so agiert kann nur
eins sagen und mit seiner sprache zu
bleiben das ist der sound der totalen
ahnungslosigkeit und so ein minister
darf eigentlich nicht für die wirtschaft
sprechen liebe freundin freunde es ist
ein desaster sei was öffentlich zu hören
[Applaus]
deswegen ihr habt da wegweisende
beschlüsse gefasst fraktion und partei
wir sind da völlig zusammen zu helfen zu
stärken
zielgerichtet mittelstand und ich sage
auch wir haben corona übrigens
wirtschaftlich überstanden weil wir da
nicht auf den euro genau gerechnet haben
dass sagt mancher das war zu viel das
ergebnis ist ein besseres gemäss zuvor
sonst wären ganze branchen pleite
gewesen und so müssen wir das jetzt auch
machen und zwar richtig konsequent
übrigens finde ich auch es nach wie vor
beachtlich dass der bund nicht bereit
ist die von ihm selbst an der inflation
verdienenden steuern zu senken ist nicht
nur die kalte progression
deutschland hat übergibt stromsteuer
deutschland hat jetzt wieder über gebühr
spritpreise deutschland hat überall viel
mehr als europa mein dringender wunsch
wenn der staat es ernst waren den
bürgern zu helfen dann darf er nicht
noch zusätzlich an hohen preisen
verdiene liebe freundin freunde und
darum muss das gesenkt werden es ist die
beste und schnellste und effektivste
methode
und übrigens auch bei lebensmitteln
es geht immer so unter aber in
supermärkten legen viele leute essen
wieder zurück wenn sie sehen wie teuer
es wird es wird unterschätzt und wird
auch mal nicht ernst genommen
ich verstehe dass immer nicht was sie
als wir beim g7-gipfel waren keine hat
gefragt
habt ihr mal bayerisches sushi oder so
alle wollten unser essen haben dass man
eben nach schweinsbraten essen oder
makrele keine ahnung ja
aber warum sind wir in deutschland
eigentlich so verbohrt wenn es um
heimische stärken geht wir könnten die
ganze welt mit nahrungsmitteln versorgen
es ist ein unserer hochwertigsten güter
niedersachsen als frühlingszeit ist ja
die besten beiden landwirtschaft ok über
frieden heute ja
[Applaus]
aber wir sind auch ziemlich gut
ich kann nur sagen warum erlauben wir
unser landwirtschaft nicht flächen zu
bewirtschaften
um nahrungsmittel zu produzieren warum
erlauben mir der landwirtschaft nicht
bioenergie und biogas zu produzieren und
warum wenn es um entlastung geht kommt
von den grünen immer nur der eine satz
wenn mir mal steuern senken dann nur auf
regale produkte auf bio produkten was
weiß ich ich sage 1 es soll jeder essen
was er will aber zu deutschland gehört
auch dazu dass das jeder entscheiden
kann dass das grüne nicht vorgeben ich
bin nicht bereit zu glauben dass man mit
brokkoli einen kindergeburtstag zum
fundamentalen erfolg führen kann lieben
freund wurde lasst uns essen was wir
wollen und senkt darauf die steuer
[Applaus]
und damit bin ich neben energie bei
einem für mich zentralsten punkt
mittlerweile das energie ist das
ideologisch behaftete nicht
entscheidenden der krise
aber es gibt etwas anders spüren sie
nicht auch viele menschen empfinden es
so überdies jenseits der schlagzeilen in
den medien
dass die ampel etwas anderes noch macht
vor der großen bühne der energiekrise
sitzen dahinter andere architekten eine
andere gesellschaft entwickeln wollen
ich kann mich erinnern dass letztes jahr
viele uns gefragt haben nun
gibt keine unterschiede mehr
jeder ist gleich
so ich überhaupt wählen ja außer den
hübschen gesichtern sonst wo
seit den 60er jahren war
ist es nicht mehr so deutlich was die
unterschiede sind und deswegen müssen
wir als union ist auch sagen ich will
euch 345 punkten die für mich 10.30 bis
erste
ihr habt euch gute entschiedenes c zu
behalten im namen es sind nicht die ktu
nicht dekade oder die kmu nicht die
glückliche die christliche menschen
nicht die ampel beginnt den schutz des
lebens zu verändern
der einstieg 219 a stgb ist der erste
schritt man spürt förmlich den wunsch
218 komplett abzuschaffen liebe freundin
freuen ich weiß
es ist keine leichte entscheidung
gewesen zwischen selbstbestimmungsrecht
und schutz des lebens zu entscheiden
aber wer wie die ampel den schutz des
lebens nicht einmal mehr erwähnt
wer bei der debatte bald und den
assistierten suizid genau gleich
argumentiert dann kann ich euch nur
sagen wir haben den schutz des lebens
aus unseren christlichen menschenbild
daraus zu beginn und am ende des lebens
als zentralen punkt gesehen liebe
freunde und wir lassen nicht zu dass der
in deutschland gestrichen oder von der
tagesordnung genommen wird dafür stehen
wir als union
[Applaus]
wirst du ihn für den lebensschutz weiter
mein freund tillmann kuban und nestor
sitzen sagt der mensch markus
töns wehrendorf eine sache wird manche
sitzung vom cdu vorstand der mittel
entspannter mag sein ich
will nur eines sagen ich bin gegen die
freigabe von drogen liebe freundin bin
dagegen
bin dagegen
[Applaus]
kein land der welt
kein land der welt ist glücklich
geworden mit der freigabe von drogen
niemand fragt uns den nachbarn den
niederländischen freundin freunde wir
werden euch sagen es war ein fehler
jetzt geht es schon weiter wir haben
noch gar nicht mal mehr diese einstufung
übrigens auch da war die aussage der
ampel naja okay dann muss der apotheker
entscheiden ob jemand süchtig ist oder
nicht
achim niveau die berliner grünen gegen
als progressivste gruppe in der doch
mittlerweile auch etwas als spießigen
grünen datei
sagen hey wenn die cannabis reicht er
nicht
sondern da muss jetzt kokain her und
christel net
wer ein gesicht eines menschen gesehen
hat er unter christel mit leidet wenn du
eines sagen ich bin als jugendlicher
habe ich dieses buch christiane f für
kinder vom bahnhof zoo gelesen und ich
bin nicht bereit unseren kindern unserer
gesellschaft eine solche verfehlte
entwicklung zuzulassen wir müssen uns
mit allem was wir haben gegen die
freigabe von drogen wären liebe freunde
sein unterschied von uns zu den anderen
drittens
in diesem sommer hatten einige flughäfen
probleme mitarbeiter mitarbeiter zu
finden und
das ist hat man entschieden um wir
müssen jetzt aus dem ausland nachfragen
ob ihr ein paar leute finden können die
an den flughäfen koffer von a nach b
transportieren so weit so gut die frage
hat aber keiner gestellt warum können
wir nicht in deutschland menschen finden
die diese tätigkeit wenn sie körperlich
stark genug sind natürlich ja warum sie
das nicht machen
es werden in deutschland die falsche
signale gesetzt dieses neue bürgergeld
klingt sicherlich besser als hartz 4
aber es ist übrigens zurück zu
lafontaine nichts anderes ich sage euch
mal eines ich bin der woche angegriffen
weil ich das gesagt habe ich stehe aber
dazu wer nicht arbeiten kann
aus körperlichen gründen wer keine
arbeitsstelle findet hat die volle
rückendeckung des sozialstaats verdient
wir aber arbeiten könnte und nicht
arbeiten will oder wer liebe freundin
freunde aufgefordert was zu tun und sagt
ich möchte das aber nicht dann kann es
doch nicht so sein dass derjenige nicht
einmal mehr die motivation nachgefragt
bekommen kann das etwas tun muss wissen
sie so viele menschen arbeiten hart und
zahlen dafür dass neue bürgergeld führt
dazu dass in münchen wahrscheinlich eine
frisörin eine friseur damit die dort
arbeitet ein
polizeibeamter vielleicht weniger
verdient als jemand mit bürgergeld das
ist doch das falsche signal wir brauchen
noch den einsatz fleiß für leistung für
bereitschaft einander zu arbeiten
[Applaus]
eine ferienregion acht anderen und die
letzte sie habe ich selber unterschätzt
noch im letzten jahr es ist diese
schleichende
sanktionierung unserer gesellschaft
dieses einteilen moralisch gut und böse
haben was richtig oder falsch sagt bis
zu einem jahr übrigens galt noch
diejenigen die ölheizung hatten als ist
eine ölheizung
heute sind die ölheizung sind die locker
ist die sagen hey willst mal duschen bei
mir
total helden ja total helfen
es geht aber noch
aber es gibt so in unserem land zone
neue bewegung
trockenes
ich habe drei viertel der deutschen sich
schwer abzuwägen was könnte das sein ja
dahinter steckt ein zutiefst in liberale
gedanke liebe freundin von ein zutiefst
in liberaler gedanken
es geht los mit einer
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte
die sagt übrigens wie die eigene
bundesregierung dass sein so viel weiß
er dabei die deutschen als hässliche
kartoffeln bezeichnet die die deutsche
wiedervereinigung als völker aussieht
also wissen sie wenn der deutsche
bundestag und die deutsche regierung
probleme hat die schuldenbremse
einzuhalten ja man kann nur eines sagen
unabhängig von schulden jemand
vielleicht machen muss oder geld
aufnehmen aber solche stellen wie eine
solche antidiskriminierungs beauftragte
die so denkt wie kann man sofort
streichen als bei bernie schuldenbremse
ab sofort ohne probleme
ich bin und wir sind sehr vergleich
berechtigung aber
meine damen und herren ist dieser
zwanghafte weg zu den ständern und den
mit sanktionen zu versehen ist er
wirklich das was die mehrzahl der
deutschen wirklich gut findet weil es
ihn bei einer veranstaltung mit bei
schützen schützenbrüdern ja warum
schützenbrüder geht gar nicht dann habe
ich extra liebe schützenschwestern und
schützenbrüder kam sofort in das muss
schützenbrüder rinnen heißen
es gibt regelwerke die das definieren
auch in der familie um das zu
entflechten
aus tante und onkel sommer künftig tomke
verwenden
opa und oma wird opa
und vater mutter werden zu elternteil
eins und zwei degradiert und welche
rolle und welchen immer die väter
bekommen können sich ja bei so einem
regelwerk ungefähr vorstellen meine
sender mutter
überall gibt es mittlerweile zwang zu
solchen bereichen und zwar nahezu
krampfhaft und wenn man dann sieht wie
in die kunstfreiheit
lieber präsident lammert eingegriffen
wird
bully herbig ist er wirklich ein sehr an
die mehrzahl der deutschen waren bayer
den mögen glaube ich alle ja der sagt
ich würde mir den schuh des manitu heute
nicht mehr trauen zu machen glaube auch
nicht dass das raumschiff surprise
wirklich total politisch korrekt ist
wenn ich das so ein gedächtnis habe dass
man den armen winnetou liebe freunde und
freunde ist ja gar nicht so absolut
winnetou anzugreifen und wer weiß was
sonst noch alles kommt einige firmen
zusammen schneewittchen und die sieben
zwerge muss umbenannt werden in
schneewittchen und die 7 gefährten ja
jim knopf und
tarzan stellen sie mal vor wenn sie
darauf kommen ein weißer mann der sich
relativ wenig bekleidet durch den
schimmel schwingt um gottes willen was
todestag bei uns im oktober fest heißt
es hier dürfte noch bestimmte lieder
singen andere nicht mehr meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich sage
ihnen eines jeder soll
in unserem land was er glaubt ist
wichtig ist ich will mehr polizei auf
den straßen aber weniger sprech und
denkt polizisten in den ideologischen
grünen stuben das braucht es nicht wir
sind ein land der freiheit und kein land
des zwanges liebe freunde
[Applaus]
und deswegen wenn wir es zusammenfassen
wir müssen das land gut durch die krise
führen wir haben die wiesn dass die
krise können damit ist bewiesen es waren
schwere entscheidungen damals haben sie
gemeinsam getroffen übrigens bund und
länder gemeinsam
ministerpräsident konferenzen ist glaube
ich können alle kollegen und kolleginnen
waren immer sehr zäh und machen auch
etwas zu lang aber immerhin 103 der
beteilung der öffentlichkeit wie schon
mal gelesen habe aber der bund hat mit
den ländern überlegt was zu schultern
ist im moment
erleben wir eine bundesregierung der es
völlig egal ist was länder und kommunen
denken die rechnungen bestellt und
selber nicht bezahlen und erst dann nach
dem es widerstand der länder gibt und
zwar aller
dein herr weiler das gesagt super idee
machen wir jetzt plötzlich dämmert es
ihnen beim nachrechnen dass es auch für
den landeshaushalt niedersachsen ein
problem bedeuten kann ich habe übrigens
auch kein problem dass wir bei tickets
reden liebe freundin freunde ich will
nur eines sagen wer ein ticket will muss
es dann auch ein stückweit bezahlen aber
ich sage auch deutschland ist nicht nur
ein land der metropolen deutschland ist
auch im land des ländlichen raumes und
wenn die ganze zeit meint den ländlichen
raum zu vernachlässigen da macht dann
den schweren fehler liebe freundin fand
es ist eben auch deutschland bis auf
deutsche realität und unsere antwort
[Applaus]
und deswegen auch zum beispiel es
beispiel
die deutschen haben eine industrie die
macht sie so unglaublich stark ein
großteil unseres wohlstandes passiert
darauf das auto mobilität wir wollen das
weiter entwickeln wir haben mit dem
modernsten firmen der welt überall in
deutschland wir machen das wir ermitteln
es weiter aber bei den grünen spürte und
spürt man jetzt auch bei der debatte
immer wieder den gleichen reflex gegen
diese zentrale industrie und gegen diese
form der mobilität im ländlichen raum zu
sein und am besten alles ab stellen egal
was gas öl kohle auto immer das gleiche
sagt 1 lasten fahrräder sind toll aber
im ländlichen raum kommt man damit nicht
durch den winter liebe freundin freunde
wir stehen zu unserem auto wir wollen
ein modernes auto und wir wollen auch
die arbeitsplätze in deutschland
erhalten liebevolle
[Applaus]
durch die krise führen die unterschiede
benennen die hand zur zusammenarbeit
reichen also friedrich merz hat es von
anfang an getan in der ganzen krise
angenommen wurde es nicht nur als mann
mal ist verfassungsrechtlich brauchte
die länder reichen die hand in der krise
angenommen wird es nicht
und dann eben zu den krisen management
kommen einfach auch unterschiede und
zwar unterschiede die wieder den
unterschied zeigen zwischen links und
bürgerlich ich weiß nicht ganz wohl um
die fdp das alles mitmacht ist weiß ich
nichts es ist keine ampel so eine linke
regierung mit der bahre gelben
farbspritzer liebe freundin freunde aber
das müssen die selber entscheiden eines
weise dabei es wird künftig wieder auf
die frage an kommen auch
gesellschaftlich links oder bürgerlich
und historisch gesehen kann man sagen
links ist immer falsch liebe freunde es
wird immer am ende ins chaos anfang
begeisterung indycars und krise immer
das gleiche
[Applaus]
und deswegen ist dieser parteitag so
wichtig wir kommen wieder zusammen
wir sind geschlossen und wir sind
entschlossen wir zeigen was wir wollen
und wir zeigen auch den menschen was die
unterschiede zu anderen parteien sind
deswegen lasst uns kämpfen lasst uns
niedersachsen erfolgreich gestalten
lasst uns unsere konzepte für die
zukunft einbringen lasst uns dem land
helfen und liebe ampel lasst euch helfen
von leuten die von krisen was verstehen
und deswegen meine damen und herren auf
in die auseinandersetzung niedersachsen
viel viel erfolg gemeinsam kämpfen für
unser land gott schütze deutschland gott
schütze die cdu und die csu l icks hat
auch auf ein gutes miteinander viel
erfolg für euch danke für die tolle
arbeit hat vielen dank
soweit wir das grußwort von markus söder
den parteivorsitzenden der csu hier auf
dem 35 cdu parteitag in hannover und bei
mir ist noch kein rudolf korte von der
universität duisburg essen haben uns die
rede gerade gemeinsam angehört das war
so eine mischung aus gier zelte laune
und natürlich auch das streicheln der
konservativen sehen sie das auch so
wahrgenommen ja
radikalkonservativer so kann es rüber
bei den gesellschaftspolitischen teil
dass sie sich an der regierung ab
arbeitet ist klar aber das
gesellschaftspolitische ganze
ideologisch aufzuspießen war interessant
weil die mehrheit jeder abgeordneter der
mitglieder oder delegierten hat seit
gestern eilig nicht gleichermaßen alles
intoniert die progressive mitte die
merkel mitte hat hier doch viele
abstimmung für sich entschieden und das
was er hier als konservatives
gesellschaftliches profil ins zentrum
seiner rede gerückt hat hat bisher hier
weil ich nicht geworden trotzdem
jubilieren ihm natürlich jetzt alle zu
das sehen wir jetzt gerade ist der
nations für markus söder er ist ein
guter redner das hat man auch schon bei
anderen parteitagen gesehen bei diesen
grußwort naja ich mich an 2009/10
beispielsweise in leipzig da hat auch
sozusagen der sah sie um das war das
letzte mal wo auch die cdu zusammen saß
das letzte mal in einem präsenz
parteitag der hat hier gesprochen auch
nochmal sie haben gesagt das abarbeiten
der regierung angenommen was waren denn
aber die punkte die sie jetzt auch
gesehen haben gerade wo es um das
konservative profil geht vorüber ja hier
auch die cdu seit gestern debattiert was
er hier noch mal ins zentrum gerückt hat
in dem hauptteil natürlich sehr an der
regierung energiepolitisch abgearbeitet
ihre fehler aufgezeigt er kann das eben
in einer rhetorischen brillanz dass er
mit humorvollen treffern auch so ein
saal hinter sich bekommen darin ist er
gibt und das ist diesmal weniger
auffallen als bei anderen parteitagen
weil auch friedrich merz sowas natürlich
kann die abgrenzung zu merkel und zu
kramp karrenbauer ist einfach rhetorisch
anders gewesen das war hier ein warten
geradezu auf solche parteitags leben das
hat er geschafft aber im
gesellschaftspolitischen teilhatte sehr
stark retro elemente bedient jährigen
gleich weiter jetzt äußert sich gerade
durch märz da gehen wir mal rein für
deine worte
ich will in diesen dank einschließen die
gute zusammenarbeit die wir in der
bundestagsfraktion und zwischen beiden
parteien haben auch mit denjenigen die
orte aus der csu bei uns zu gast sind
lieber martin huber generalsekretär der
csu herzlich willkommen bei uns und
lieber alexander dobrindt auch dir noch
einmal ein herzliches willkommen auf dem
bundesparteitag der cdu
[Applaus]
von diesem parteitag gehen für cdu und
csu zwei botschaften aus erstens wir
arbeiten gut
freundschaftlich
vertrauensvoll zusammen wir arbeiten
zusammen wir kämpfen zusammen bestreiten
um die politischen themen in diesem
lande und wir sind dabei geschlossen wie
selten zuvor
aber es gibt noch eine zweite botschaft
und markus ich bin sehr dankbar dass du
das hier so zum ausdruck gebracht hast
und ich denke wir können das als die
beiden parteivorsitzenden von cdu und
csu ihr noch einmal so deutlich sagen
das gilt für die länder und dass es
gerade gesagt als ministerpräsident des
freistaates bayern wir bieten der
bundesregierung in diesen schweren
wochen und monaten eine zusammenarbeit
an
ausdrücklich der ministerpräsidenten mit
der bundesregierung und ich sage das für
die gemeinsame bundestagsfraktion von
cdu und csu auch der bundestagsfraktion
mit der bundesregierung ja wir streiten
um die einzelheiten wir haben an vielen
punkten eine andere meinung aber es ist
in einer solchen schweren zeit auch
notwendig
zusammenzuarbeiten
wir bieten es von hier aus ausdrücklich
noch einmal an die bundesregierung aus
der sicht der fraktion aber auch an die
bundesregierung aus der sicht der länder
und der ministerpräsidenten der union
herzlichen dank dass du das hier noch
einmal so klar und deutlich gesagt hast
wir sind nicht nur opposition wir sind
in vielen ländern regierung und
gemeinsam cdu und csu bieten der
bundesregierung an dort wo es immer
möglich ist und wir zu gemeinsamen
lösungen kommen auch gemeinsam zu
handeln
wenn die bundesregierung ist jetzt nicht
annimmt dann ist es allein ihre
verantwortung auch das werden wir dann
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
deutlich machen lieber markus
du hast den ziemlich genau einem jahr in
bayern die landtagswahlen
und dass sie sich deswegen noch einmal
eine schlussbemerkung zum strategischen
miteinander von cdu und csu machen und
der eine oder andere von ihnen kennt das
was ich jetzt sagen aber ich will es
ganz ausdrücklich hier noch einmal
wiederholen es gibt unter den
christdemokratischen parteien in europa
kein einziges beispiel so wie wir in
einer solchen
gemeinsamkeit einer bundestagsfraktion
von zwei parteien die territorial
abgegrenzt sind gegeneinander
die sich aber so gegenseitig
unterstützen und helfen die cdu und csu
es gibt wählerinnen und wähler in bayern
die wählen die csu weil sie wissen dass
es eine starke cdu gibt und es gibt
wählerinnen und wähler im rest der
republik die wählen die cdu
weil sie wissen dass es eine starke csu
in bayern gibt wir schöpfen auf diese
art und weise ein wählerpotenzial aus
dass wir gegeneinander oder schlicht und
ergreifend mit einer partei allein nicht
erreichen könnten und ich werde alles
tun was in meiner kraft steht bei
unterschieden die notwendig und richtig
sind und die wir auch austragen
miteinander und die auch der aufgaben
lage entsprechen aber ich werde alles
tun um diese fraktionsgemeinschaft von
cdu und csu zusammen zu halten weil nur
diese fraktionsgemeinschaft und das gute
miteinander von cdu und csu der
erfolgsgarant dafür ist dass wir auch
die nächste bundestagswahl wieder
gewinnen liebe freundinnen und freunde
und deswegen über markus
deswegen lieber markus geht das was wir
beide miteinander tun und liebe
alexander geht das was wir beide in der
bundestagsfraktion miteinander tun weit
über unser persönliches gutes verhältnis
hinaus wir haben hier eine verantwortung
für die gesamte union die wir mit
jeweils unterschiedlichen funktionen
ausfüllen und ausüben und wir werden
nach kräften darum weiter bemüht bleiben
so wie uns das in diesem jahr gelungen
ist diese gemeinsamkeiten aufrecht zu
erhalten auszubauen und zu zeigen dass
wir wirklich gemeinsam cdu und csu die
nummer eins in deutschland sind und
bleiben über das jahr 2022 hinaus lieber
markus in diesem sinne herzlichen dank
für dein kommen gute rückreise nach
münchen viel erfolg bei der landtagswahl
im nächsten jahr und am 29 oktober sehen
wir uns auf dem landesparteitag der csu
in bayern in augsburg ich werde die
einladung dort genauso gern annehmen wie
du heute herzlich empfangen worden bist
bei der cdu in deutschland herzlichen
dank für deinen kopf
[Applaus]
ja soweit hier die erwiderung von
friedrich merz den vorsitzenden der
union und er hat den csu parteitag
angesprochen da berichten wir natürlich
auch wieder live von phoenix für sie
aber bei mir ist noch karl rudolf korte
wir haben da die erwiderung von herrn
merz direkt gehört auf die grußworte von
herrn söder so ein bisschen muss man
sich die augen reiben er hat ja gerade
etwas beschrieben was ja vor allem das
problem war die der zwist zwischen cdu
und csu der ein grund war für die
verlorene bundestagswahl ist jetzt das
amalgam jetzt hier wieder gelegt für den
streit der da war nehmen sie das so war
dass das angebot was ihm erst einmal
unterstreicht die wunden halten was
heißt das jetzt dass wirkt glaubhaft das
angebot das ist die versöhnte
verschiedenheit die hier gelebt wird
aber ob die brücke schon belastbar sind
die man versucht neu aufzubauen das wird
sich zeigen man muss viele
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen noch
starten in der bundestagsfraktion
genauso wie zwischen den beiden parteien
die hauptbelastung spor bekommt dann
wieder mit der nominierung des
kanzlerkandidaten oder kanzlerkandidatin
da wird sich zeigen ob die
brückenbauarbeiten auch tragfähig war
denn die wunden sind ziemlich groß in
beiden parteien die aufgerissen sind ja
unter sagt friedrich merz beispielsweise
in einem interview das am letzten wochen
im sommer interview gesagt dass das noch
nicht beantwortet ist die
kanzlerkandidatenfrage ist ja auch noch
ein bisschen zeit bis 2025
abschlussfrage weil dieser parteitag
steht ja vor allen dingen auch
letztendlich mit seinem blick ins
zentrum darauf gerichtet welche
programmatischen punkte die union finden
muss für eben genau diesen lauf was ist
ihre einschätzung jetzt im moment an
diesem zweiten tag vielleicht auch die
bilanz an dieser stelle einmal wir haben
sie die debatten wahrgenommen um
frauenquote beispielsweise aber was
erwarten sie jetzt auch noch denn heute
geht es ja auch noch um andere dinge wie
zum beispiel das gesellschafts jahr also
sammeln und suchen so würde ich das
zusammenfassen sammeln die position
opposition im bund zu sein das ist neu
für diese partei da muss man sich ein
bisschen schütteln und suchen als
bewegung nach den mobilisierungsthema
die auch kompetenz ausstrahlen gegenüber
wählerinnen und wählern und dieser
prozess hat heute erst gestattet und wir
werden den weiter beobachten sie auch
ich sage ganz herzlichen dank karl
rudolf gott professor der universität
duisburg essen für diese einschätzung
zum moment